at all of my enemies 32 what's going on
I'm Kevin Hart aka K Hart aka the real
deal
aka that guy and I'm about to be quiz on
a life everybody what's going on dwayne
johnson here AKA the rock aka la rocca
aka that guy I said daagon know but I
said it differently thank God enough
stop this is ridiculous
there we go now I'm ready okay alright
complete Dwayne's twitter bio chivalrous
gentleman just add the kid just ah got
it
just add what I love to drink fine
ah terra-man fine Thank You Ramona took
you okay my question are you ready
complete Kevin's Twitter bio my name is
Kevin Hart and I am a piece of [ __ ]
that's not a piece of in my in my bio
and your bio I'm gonna say I'm a piece
of [ __ ] in my bio
do not say that in my bio the kind of
comedian you are self-deprecating like
that evidence of what makes you
brilliant you know I work hard there you
go
that that's not in your bias my heart
just says I work hard yes so that's like
I'm Kevin Hart I have a [ __ ]
heartbeat all right I breathe air it
what is that I'm Dwayne the rock Johnson
I drink tequila no that's I know but at
least that's fun yeah that generally
read your bio and goes Wow [ __ ] yeah he
works hard
just wet I'm Dwayne right job yeah I'm a
grown man sometimes I drink alright
that's good see the point either one of
us should get a point yes
maybe we should change
I have that okay biles will be changed
after the day Oh your turn
Duane went to the University of Miami
what did he study while he was there
study what you study like like as in
educate yourself as in yes I'm like ah I
tried to get better it's real my
textbooks and Wow um cars changing
batteries and cars it's gotta be uh if
it's a subject
um alright [ __ ] let's take a crack at it
communications good communication was a
good choice that's not it no no no I
wanted to work for the CIA
well thank God that didn't what's that
supposed to mean just come be a great
agent for the agency and we'd be in
trouble I said criminology alright oh
this is good you're gonna get this one
this is too easy then what are you doing
it's too easy okay guys go to the hard
ones yeah ready oh okay this is a good
one uh which concert does Kevin say was
the first concert he attended in his
life you got to know this one let's
break it down comedy yeah got it yep you
went to see comedian or was it a group
no it was group a group it was a group
Kings economy Sesame Street oh nice
when when you were a kid no I was like
18 17 8 that's a cool cool thing no need
to judge it I'm not judging something I
thought was cool to do man
yeah let's do what more aged yeah it
finally going DJ I found a roadkill when
looking at those questions you probably
realize how uninteresting you are
completely Wow okay
in 2000 which rapper did Duane
collaborate with on the single it
doesn't matter is that the song is that
are you singing a song yeah it doesn't
matter name of the song where's that
from it doesn't matter why does that
what this is what he said like that who
is that that is that that's like iconic
[ __ ] well Oprah that doesn't matter Lexy
well Oprah does that when she goes out
of cars it doesn't matter who you are
you get a car you get a car you get a
car let's do that but she doesn't that's
not that's not no no yes no no no no
vanilla ice ice baby no it doesn't
matter if you like ice cream
Oh Wyclef remember you know right yeah
last one you gotta get this is it's
gotta get this one according to Google
how tall is kept
okay according to google google yes okay
is this the legit answer because I know
it or is this do I [ __ ] with you on this
which one go I think you should go for
what you know well go for what I know
legit answer legit legit legit because I
know you're my best friend forefoot -
yes
that's legit hey you actually have me
sold he's gonna get it no come on okay
okay five six five five no five four
five four but in in in centimeters
within my centimetres column is enemy's
30 to one point six to one centimeters
tall it was a draw to draw
[ __ ] damn it damn it all right I
don't understand why it's better this is
good you guys always have a very good
[ __ ] thing me I'll do a good job guys
yes